soldiers loyal to yemen's u.n
recognized president abdulrahman suhadi
are facing their biggest challenging
years
preventing healthy fighters from taking
control of marib
the province east of the capital sana is
rich in oil and natural gas
it's also had his last chance to regain
control of yemen
but the houthis have been sending
reinforcements
they know the battle of marib could
decide the future
of the country further south
fighting has intensified around the city
of tyres
government forces have launched an
offensive to retake military bases
controlled by elite army units loyal to
the houthis
the iran-backed rebels hold ground in
ties
to prevent government forces from
advancing towards
marib in the north violence is spiraling
out of control
while that's going on the houthis have
launched an attack targeting oil
facilities in saudi arabia
the artillery and drone divisions were
able to conduct a wide offensive
in the depths of saudi arabia with 14
drones
and eight ballistic missiles we targeted
aramco in ras
altanura port and other military
facilities in damam
more military sites were targeted in
assyria and jazan and the strike was
precise
but saudi arabia says its air defenses
intercepted the drone and missile
attacks
retaliation was swift the saudi
coalition launched airstrikes in the
capital sanaa
the escalation comes as the u.s envoy to
yemen is visiting the region
to rally support for an end to the
conflict
timothy lander king is hoping to bring
all the parties
and give diplomacy a chance but the last
breakthrough in yemen
was short-lived in 2019
the u.n convinced the warring factions
to agree on a ceasefire
a prisoner swap and political talks on
the future of the country
weeks later the deal collapsed and
fighting has not stopped
ever since hashem alberta al-jazeera